I feel like the Hollywood thing going
forward is gonna be alright we're gonna
take an actor who's known generally for
comedic things so John Krasinski has
stepped out of it since the office but
he's more or less known for the office
we'll have them direct a thriller
because apparently it really works
[Music]
a quiet place so what quiet place is
directed by John Krasinski he also gets
writing credit on the movie along with a
couple of other people and it more or
less revolves around this family in this
house in the middle of what looks like a
farm and for a while now they have dealt
with this situation the situation being
is kind of a post-apocalyptic scenario
you don't see much outside the farm so
you don't really know how the rest of
the world is dealing with it I can't
glance at all the newspaper clippings I
saw somewhat get the gist just being
there are these aliens in the world
really feral aliens and if you make a
sound they are drawn to sound if they
hear you they will scamper over to you
and tear you apart they'll shred you
lose this family trying to sneak around
going about their day-to-day not making
sound those sounds probably will happen
and we've now set the stage for a very
effective thriller call it a thriller I
know some people like I don't like
horror movies not as much a horror movie
as it is a thriller a very fine line
between thriller and horror movie I feel
like this movie really walks at well
everyone in this movies great John
Krasinski and Emily Blunt there's a
scene in particular where I'm like emily
Blunt's crushing it right now I even
have a couple of kids in the movie
sometimes that is just your day away at
that point not these kids these kids are
great I'm kind of doing a flyby talking
about oh they were all good in the movie
but really they're great in the sense
that one very huge part of communication
is generally speaking gone in his movies
everything they have to do they have to
convey without words all the fear all
the intensity any of the emotions their
face their body language these are the
tools because their voices just can't
happen they can't talk they do they do
sign language in the movie that's the
primary form of communication but let me
just say that this is a thriller based
on life and death in which the most
intense of conversations are conveyed
through sign language and it completely
works that's not very conventional
they'll do a fantastic job operating in
this world this movie has brought you
into immediately this movie brings you
in on this world where you as the
audience you feel like you can barely
breathe you definitely can't make any
sounds there were these people behind me
they were talking as the movie was
starting I was like oh my god a few
times no immediately you get that
feeling of oh we can't make sounds and
the theaters shut up even people who
cough they were like oh my god nope you
die not quiet enough it's quite a thing
when you can make the audience really
feel like they're in the movie to the
point where it's like making any sounds
whatsoever people are critical in their
rappers to get their candy like and it
doesn't so effectively because it
illustrates how easy it is to make sound
as homo sapiens are not stealthy the
human race we're loud we're clunky we're
not quiet
that's why stealth is a skill that you
have to
faster I drop a little knickknacks and
things all the time but if you do that
in this world you die a big thing this
movie illustrates it's how adaptable
people are you will adapt to survive in
most situations and if you don't adapt
good news you get to die early so you
can see how they get food you get to see
their operations it makes the world feel
very lived in a movie like this or any
apocalyptic type setting when it
revolves around a family or a group of
people and they don't really show how
will they be survived if I allow myself
to pick it apart I have to ask the
question like how have you survived this
long this movie shows how they've
survived this long it shows they do have
a system doesn't mean this movie doesn't
drag on in part so for my first watch I
was still glued I was like it shows the
world I really this movie makes you
reflect on human beings in general how
much we rely on noise for communication
for a release I don't know how this
movie got conjured up but the fact that
they're in a very intense scenario I
almost feel like someone was in a very
intense scenario and they just had to
release it had to scream they had to
have a big cry and they thought what if
you couldn't do that and that's what you
really feel in this movie no one can cry
no one can scream no one can take a
stick and smack a tree with it so all
the pain anger and emotions as families
dealing with they haven't had a release
that is straight up a version of hell
they're in hell and since they're
feeling that this movie does a good job
of bringing you into the movie you start
feeling it every intense scenario and
there are a few of them you don't have
release you don't go you actually do the
and you stop breathing this movie really
preys on your fight-or-flight and you
just freeze in place gotta hand it to a
movie for doing that I mean when you
first meet the family having all the
noise go out when the cameras on the
girl and having the ambient always come
back when the cameras on the Sun it's
genius and illustrating a couple things
not only one of the things about one of
the characters but also illustrating the
contrast between quiet and sound does
she realize how noisy the world is thus
you realize how hard it is to be quiet
cause you realize the danger but I start
to roll my eyes are moments where I'm
like alright I've seen this before in
movies and it was just as cliche there
well there'd be a particular scenario
I'm not gonna spoil anything there's a
scenario that takes longer than the 10
minutes it actually took and any time
you have to bloody hand slapping onto
the window I'm like that is just that's
just how many times does that happen
well chalk up one more because in the a
quiet place was really unique my biggest
flaw in the movie he's just simply where
the movie ends not that the movie ends
but where the movie ends where they
decided to go you know what that's the
end end credits just didn't like it
gonna keep it vague but personally with
me did not dig that choice but in the
end I thought John Krasinski crushed it
every
the movie did a great job I was at the
edge of my seat I was white knuckling it
and I will say a quiet place is
definitely worth watching and definitely
worth buying on blu-ray one of those
movies you watch like I want my friends
to watch this movie even if they just
watch it once I want them to watch it
once I said what quiet place have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and if you subscribe to me ring
that Bell icon / YouTube's algorithm it
does help me out and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]